hey guys it's gregory alba here your
fellow reject and i have with me today
wendee lee from collider videos and the
movie couple channel wendy is highly
intelligent super articulate very fast
and her thoughts quick-witted i feel a
definite larious you're building me up
no i don't believe in overselling anyone
you'll see you'll see so we're gonna do
our top 10 favorite movies of the summer
of 2016 those are all the movies from
the months of may to august in 2016 I'll
kick this off my number 10 is finding
dory finding dory was it was nice it
wasn't like a surprise in any capacity
and it wasn't exactly like completely
original however it was like a great
family film I was really impressed with
Ellen DeGeneres in that film because i
remember when i heard it and even saw
the trailer i was like how are they
really gonna make Dory from a supporting
character to a lead I thought she was a
great lead they had a great character
another name Hank play by head O'Neill
it was hilarious reminded me of my dad a
little bit and i really like God the
animation was really fun and all and but
and I really love I don't know themes
about family and identity that gets to
me and man finding your home and the
home within yourself too and it's really
about the loved ones that was a great
cheesy time and yeah highly recommended
Pixar ones again you know I had my
doubts about that movie when I first
heard it was finding Dory because like
you said how are they gonna make a
secondary character from the first movie
yeah i thought i was gonna find dory in
large doses really really annoying yeah
i love the movies yeah they managed to
really flush her out in a way where
you're like i enjoy watching her i mean
i was kinda disappointed what they did
with Nemo and Marlin cuz I thought they
were kind of just unnecessary throughout
the whole movie but it was still really
cool to see like Ellen DeGeneres like
that little marketing move but making
her the lead actually worked for my
number 10 whoops i'm about to airdrop
the note to somebody else my number 10
was Jason Bourne nah make my list whoa
why I liked it because and I know a lot
of people didn't like it but I am such a
big fan
the original born I read I read the book
and I love Matt Damon it was nice to see
everything everybody come back to this
franchise and just kind of list through
a good feel good action movie you know
watch him do some kung Fu's I'm fighting
with the guns and tactical stuff you
know yeah I mean it's cool to see him
come back and the fighting is there I
was just I was pretty let down by that
film I think my anticipation was very
high for it but I was I don't feel like
that they failed really yeah I feel I
felt like they still don't each their
own opinion this is true art of the
glory democracy I'm really this alicia
vikander yeah that's up with her accent
in the movie she suppose to be American
or she supposed to be Irish she goes it
sound like a mix of both to me pissed me
off mm-hmm I agree with you plenty
thanks John my shoulder angel I cannot
get over how disappointing that film was
well that's good that's a Wendy's number
10 but that's okay my number 9 choice
I'm going with a comedy here my number
nine choices Central Intelligence I
really really enjoyed that film i know i
did like some gigs with them to help
promote Central Intelligence of blu-ray
release some web series you can see I'm
Warner Brothers home entertainment page
didn't have loaded on this channel 20
you ever see that little mark ellis and
josh mokuba oh I heard about that when
they did the CIA trained yeah yeah Josh
heated like he had this big idea was
like I'm like you don't no one uses that
gun sideways he's like but I look cool
poo poo poo Josh in real life is exactly
what you'd imagine it to be like what is
like hanging out with Josh on camera
that's been one or seven say to you why
did I competed just a goofball man
anyway Central Intelligence it's not
like the most clever film or necessarily
the most witty it's one of those films
that really is just really great because
of the rock and Kevin Hart we're talking
about summer movies here and if you want
to go watch a movie that you just want
to laugh with the whole time and I
thought I found myself cracking up that
entire film i thought was [ __ ]
hilarious did you see it I didn't get
the chance to see it I'm gonna through
my pockets all last weekend I made it on
this list nice got the blue it probably
wouldn't meet her my list by actually
I am [ __ ] funny I like the rock a lot
I met him when I was 18 the cheesecake
factory was on my birthday I didn't know
who he was and I was trying to get
attention my waitresses attention cuz I
wanted like a family photo yeah I think
birthday and she was like lean against
the wall just like staring at him dreamy
on psych who is this guy my god father
said that's the rock who rock the
wrestling what kind of the name is the
rock anyways and I was all frustrated
pouting and he stands up and you know
he's tossed I was like mmm I just
offended him I just totally offended him
with my his name and he's like with the
smile I can take that picture for you
haha and I was like okay energy is he
dreamy oh my god totally he's done I was
like okay I'm your fan oh look I don't
even never what you do you can be into a
guy that buff totally really good well
what did I i'm more of a Kevin Hart kind
of guy I like him small later ah good
things comes in small packages yeah yeah
that's what they always tell me too ok
Wendy your next member guy my number
nine is Star Trek beyond so while I am a
star wars girl through and through I
seriously love the rehash the newer Star
Trek I actually really quite enjoyed
crisp lines in these series wasn't
really sure about him in the very
beginning I was like him Captain Kirk
really hmm I'm not sure but I've
completely fell in love with the
franchise and I Oh slow love love love
attack open Joe yeah he's [ __ ]
awesome I'm such a fan so I'd love
everything they've done and i think is
probably the best one I think Star Trek
beyond did not make my list too but it's
generally loved my people kind of like
that we have very country feeling we'll
get some similar films in soon yes let's
find out my number eight here is where
the world turns against the real rejects
but maybe that's what we called the real
rejects maybe it's a gimmick who knows
ghostbusters the one with all the chicks
I really enjoyed that film I thought it
was really funny and I was one of those
people who was very much opposed against
it went even when I saw the trailers I
was ready to hate this film no it's not
better than the first one at all it's
not even one of my favorite movies of
this year but it serves
summer movies I had a really good time I
laughed my ass off the route chris
hemsworth is hilarious in the film yeah
he's hysterical kaun Yin is there
something special one like a guy who
normally does serious roles doesn't
comedy yeah you know like when James
Franco did pineapple express or when
chance and with 21 Jump Street and now
to let's see like Chris Hemsworth doing
that I would like to see Chris Hemsworth
room in morals and while that movie
didn't make my list I still very much
enjoyed it Dustin like a bash not her
channel just for saying that we liked
the movie I'm like well what's why can i
like this movie and they're saying what
do we say that they were astray w's and
that we're feminist and we're just
afraid of being named called and I was
like oh I'm getting an ink on right now
so what does it matter if I hate them we
don't like the movie so let's just be
out with it I like to have fun with it
and Ron and tomatoes is biased against
DC alter the lighters being bought off
by marble exactly because it's all true
all faxed all facts you guys are right
my number 8 it's a horror movie it's
lights out lights out that is on my list
will be higher up let's see what you got
sick I love that they turned a two
minute short into a full feature movie
and I was like how can they do this
because the creature was already
established she'd only exists in the
dark I've never felt so uncomfortable
coming out of the movie walking back
into my dark apartment and wanting to
flick on all the lights yeah but all the
lights on which I did your first two
nights really yeah did that to you have
a horror movie really i mean i missed
our time I list supernatural things like
that really freaked me out and I know
like a you know creature like this never
technically exist yeah yeah baby thing
and sometimes you click that light off
and you see a shadow you're like what
was that you turn it on and then
sometimes you just want to leave office
some things are just meant to be seen
did you grow up religious no no no I'm a
grew up religion and that's why that
shape and scare me I believe I'm not
religious currently yeah I think it
shows my attitude and personality and
who I am overall is a human being I
don't know why so that was such a smile
anyway because you believe in it cuz I
believe it demons and things gonna
happen may have actually never saw the
short did you see the short you need to
do a reaction to the short are you
me feel we need to do this right after
that i'm not even kidding we're doing
taking over the other get it ready my
number 7 choice i put down a harlot yeah
it's a horror movie the shallows you see
that i didn't get to see it i really
really enjoyed this movie blake lively I
thought did an amazing job it's kind of
questionable when you first see the
trailer because we're like is she just
gonna be eye candy you know like yeah
she's cause she's in bikini the whole
movie about like 20 minutes in when like
the shark stuff actually starts
happening you that's not I candy anymore
now you just got like a vulnerable woman
who's just like half-naked surround them
but like on a rock and a shark trying to
get her and I thought I was very
cleverly scripted it gets a little like
be horror movie and a little cheesy
towards the last half of the film but I
still thought it was a great movie I
thought Blake Lively like totally nailed
the role and I was wildly impressed
there's no shark that was ever used on
set right so to see a movie with such
emotional depth of the actress and no
that's all imagination like nothing to
work off of very impressive primarily
her performance is why i recommend it I
told me grant way I wish I'd seen it I
was busy so I didn't get to go to the
screening and then I just kind of moved
on but uh yeah I agree with you I think
being the only actress in the movie of
nothing not a human not even like a
tennis ball to play against that's not
feeding you any sort of emotion it's
hard so I applaud her for her work in
this movie you know how jaws like they
said that was scary from going to the
beach again you this movie will scare
you from travelling on your own to a
spanish-speaking country I'm going to a
secluded beach and then can I swimming
wake surfing way out into the middle of
that water pass that's the tagline
register don't trap yeah traveler
brought to you by the show alright my
number seven is also another horror
movie it's the conjuring 2 that's on my
list as well eyes are just a little hot
money
yeah I'm i zoom much higher yeah okay
lips all right Cheers jeans one man he I
cannot wait to see more horror movies
from this man it seriously creeped me
out and a lot of the effects that
effects effects that they are happy
thanks G sex in this movie SFX in this
movie really just had me convinced that
the kids were seeing this the mom was
seeing this especially the crooked man y
is my favorite and I seriously was
wishing that they would have a spin-off
for the quick command eventually oh hell
yeah already has its own little
cinematic universe yeah and of course
the nun super scary in the room with the
painting when the nun popped out oh my
god oh my god I think I um when I get
scared I laughs I don't scream I don't
cry don't flinch I just laughed that's
cuz you go into denial the boys are you
giggling the whole movie I was giggling
I was hiding behind my press sheets and
I was like scare the whole time yes
fresh sheets you bring sheets to the
movies precious yes I bring sheets to
the movies so I can be comfortable
because I baby theatre much every day
hello would not be nice okay really laid
back now they have like Laos shares yeah
yeah twenty bucks ago in [ __ ] no it's
like just like a packet of just facts
about the after the director Oh synopsis
and 10 cuz you go to like special
screenings I'm just depressed meetings
there are I opression i was thinking of
actual she pressed cheese I don't run
really get invited to press treaties why
didn't I mean we'd like to hit house
about a movie studios pay attention this
guy right yeah please finis a midnight
play the movies cost a lot of money so
my number six choice is another comedy
that I didn't see in the theaters but
eventually watched it on DVD neighbors
to sorority rising did you see this I
did did you not like it I like they just
didn't make the list I like the first
one better oh yeah that's fair that's
totally fair I think the first ones
overall a better movie um but this one I
thought was still hysterical I thought
Zac Efron was really [ __ ] funny like
this that's another that's another thing
of I like an actor who was like as a
knife became a high school musical was
trying to like like more dramatic work
but when he did neighbors I feel like a
lot of like
guys start respecting him yeah because
he was like genuinely really [ __ ]
funny in the film na I think it's
hysterical in this film seeing that guy
caught up in the past Seth Rogen and
Rose Byrne I love all the parental
themes they explored with them their
kind of parenting is really based on
like psychological neglectful behavior
and it's like moat by parents in real
life they just don't realize we're being
bad parents but you can still see it i
like the heart and i loved how to
explore the themes of sexism and it was
at those a very witty film it's more
ridiculous it's much more like surreal a
little bit more zany and cartoony yeah
so it's not as grounded in reality but I
still thought it was a hilarious time
and the only reason why it's not even on
my top 10 it's because I felt like
they'd be cycle on the same jokes from
the first movie that's fair there's a
recycled premise for sure yeah but I
still had a good time I had a lot of
good chuckles in this film and I love
seeing Rose Byrne and Seth Rogen kind of
freaked out while their parenting and
and while trying to keep their voices
hush because the baby was sleeping yeah
just in this like frantic chaos they
were so funny but that last moment when
they're under that last scene they have
with her child and her in the bed and
they're crying I start turning up a
little bit yeah parenting stuff gets me
like that John and I thought of a
neighbor's movie idea where would be
neighbors like the same movie but on
Halloween oh my god there's three trick
or treat or something would it be like
their teenage daughter old enough now to
go out for her first hollowing is she
doesn't she wants to wear more skin
showing type connection parent yo trying
to parent her Wendy and I are movie
fights pitch neighbors three I wouldn't
last a second I movie nights you don't
think so kind of nerve-racking live
everyone's a little bit pretty
intimidating for my number six which was
your number ten finding dory okay well
much higher much higher I'm I have a
soft spot for disney and
nation and I feel like I'm basically a
tell about her I never grew up so cute
the kids dying big that's I especially
love when Dory found the shells and to
know that her parents were still looking
for her that brought it here to my eyes
oh did it mm-hmm oh I think I cried in
her net moving so cute I tend to cry at
movies it no shame yeah yeah nothing no
biggie not a [ __ ] from a [ __ ] so my
number five choice was a cool little
horror flick called don't breathe don't
breathe was an exciting film it was
tense it was [ __ ] nerve wracking it
was awesomely shot Jane levy I thought
gave a great performance I love any role
where they start off as like this
person's definitely not likable and they
haven't done anything redeeming so far
so other than the fact that she's a nice
older sister that's like the only
redeeming quality she has at first it's
one of those movies that knows how to
flip the way how I felt about the
devil's rejects was they take the
villains and then they like flip it work
they're not really the bad guys by the
end and same thing with don't breathe
it's like Stephen Lang was really scary
there were times where he kind of just
suddenly appears but I have felt like
fede alvarez really knew how to toy with
this audience I thought the script was
so carefully woven that they were able
to really structure everything out
perfectly like well people might say why
don't they do this why don't do they do
this one hand it and they would go for
it and it established why they can or
can't do that ya know my number five is
the nice guys oh if I malas coming up
guys yes guys I love that I love that
movie yeah oh it was so good and it was
it wasn't one of my most anticipated
movie of 2016 because amongst all these
like reboots and remakes I wanted
something original and when they when I
saw the trailer I was like this is this
is gonna be is gonna be my top favorite
movie beer hence inmate number five so
my number for choice is lights out
actually it's high up there I really
like lights out I was one of the most
fun times I had at the theaters because
it was such a nice surprise for horror
movies because it starts off in a way
where it's like you think a lot time you
think you kind of know how things were
gonna go it seems like this is gonna be
generic this is gonna be obvious and I
love def I love a film same thing with
don't breathe I love a phone where did
rector is aware of what his audience
would be thinking and knows how to pull
a twist on it and knows how to pull
something fresh to it I thought the
storyline maria bello and the ghost was
very well done and very different well
it was such a simple concept of the
lights go out and that's when she
appears it's so simple but it's so
[ __ ] terrifying and it's so it's
executed so well and yeah actually the
night when I did come home I do remember
being berries just a little bit you feel
that we usually you can't help what kind
of like just look a little like what are
you don't want to look into it i think
the boyfriend in the film wow he's like
the NBA he's all my notes in here yeah
boyfriend in the film alexandre de
persia as Brent he was such a nice
surprise cuz he starts off you my first
thought right when you see I'm not gonna
say what his outcome is in the film but
right when I saw him like oh he's the
boyfriend we're supposed to kind of like
and then he'll get killed off I mean
that's something do this character they
made him made him very likable yeah one
hundred percent I was like alright
alright I like use a hole for my number
four it's actually don't breathe nice
and when we we recently had Stephen Lang
in studio and I went to shake his hand
because hello Stephen Lang and he's like
oh you can call me slang that's cool I
was like all right slang did you talk
about the turkey baster scene he's bring
it up with him I didn't kind of our
thing and I bring your turkey banjo man
that movie while talk about not not
wanting to breathe during the mood
especially in the basement where in the
wind be actors were left incomplete
pitch dark yeah oh I couldn't I couldn't
take it my heart I was hiding once again
behind my press notes I really love that
they didn't do night vision for that
thank God right it's different it's
better yeah yeah because it's like it's
it makes the audience kind of look to
like what's attack oh no I do so you
kind of get fully invested yeah tennis
together there's someone not seeing
what's going on to you know my number
three now is the conjuring part dos
conjuring one I really did enjoy I
thought it was a really well-made film
but I didn't love it as much as everyone
else did conjuring too though I really
really really enjoyed it's more of a
straight-up horror film than the first
one was but I thought it improved upon
the first one there are more scares and
I thought
you really get to see James Wan get even
more clever with his trickery of the
camera not only does he do cool camera
angles he liked the way the film's
edited the way everything's shot
everything's framed perfectly done the
little girl in the movie Madison wolf is
the little girl who gets possessed and I
thought she was so [ __ ] good it's so
nice seeing it what I like to was that
this is an American film that took place
in London they got like real British
people the lay of this British family
everyone felt so authentic i like i love
whether they're going with the Warrens
and they actually put the Warrens in
danger this time yeah I just thought it
was a really well craft of film and it
was also really fun really suspenseful
and also has more of the James Wan like
some insidious vibes in there too that I
felt like the conjuring didn't need but
it but I like seeing in the conjuring 2
I almost want to say that the sequel the
in the conjuring series the sequels
better than the original yeah in at
least in my opinion I would say that too
in my opinion as well yes in our opinion
our collective doesn't have to be yours
ours just hours sorry now sorry alright
what my number three it's captain
america civil war nice yes I had to put
a Marvel movie in there cuz y'all know
how much I like Disney and Marvel you
know sometimes I call it the Avengers
2.5 yeah because it kind of feels like
it but that your poor seat though
airport scene is [ __ ] fantastic
everything's fantastic the stunt
fighting is fantastic see spider-man is
just mind-blowing and I also had a
chance to UM go and hang out with the
stunt guys that was in the movie and I
did um well quick little fight with the
stunt double for Hawkeye that's so cool
it's on the collider Channel did a fight
I did a fight it was I'll show it to you
after its it was a lot of fun it was a
lot of fun and just you know us to
really appreciate these guys working
hard I go what's happening now you're
not really putting to captain Merrick on
thurs promoting another Collider video
but I didn't we tell them we divorce
what's it called it wasn't hard movie
talk and I can't remember which one it
was well you guys comment below and find
it four times me hey so my number two is
actually the nice guys if I had to list
my favorite films so far that have come
out this year like I saw lala land early
so that's her
number one favor film for sure right now
nice guys is number two meaning from all
the films I've been released nice guys
is my number one favorite but in terms
of the summer movies I would say it's
number two hope that makes sense anyway
I've seen it twice now I think it's one
of its the most witty script of the year
I think that Ryan Gosling is so
hilarious yes movie and i love it when
he gets a chance it really shows
showcases comedy skills as we know more
as a serious actor but like Lars and the
real girl he's really funny and he's
really funny and crazy stupid love and I
thought he was hilarious in this film
and it's a different kind of character
to cuz he's not strong he's kind of a
wimp yeah and he gets he really does get
scared easily like he's a really even
erotic drunk I thought he was a really
funny character I was talking with John
about this I can't think of another film
Russell Crowe did that was a comedy I
know he did like some weird romantic
comedy with never really Scott directed
but this is like a straight-up calm
accommodatin who this is yeah it's been
a while and I thought I remember Ryan
Gosling had some of the best chemistry
of the year the second time I watched it
I got more from it because you realize
that there's not one wasted line of
dialogue in that fell everything they
say that sometimes seems like a
throwaway or not that important
eventually comes back to serve a purpose
even if it's just a joke at first it
comes back to serve a purpose I thought
was very clever and I love the little
girl in the film too i had zero faith in
her father yeah add it to the coming
here definitely my bad dad and then she
drives off in the car Thank You the man
I eat up my dad she was she said it so
matter of fact I wait I can't wait to
see more from her for me my number two
is how or high water I am fasting them
that same I if you got it you gotta go
see it you guys it's so good and I know
some people are calling it a Western I
guess it's kind of like a modern Western
set in Texas it was so hard for me to
not put it in the number one spot just
because the dialogue the story and the
human relationship you have in this
movie it's so deep and the way the story
unravels these two brothers and their
you know it's a bank heist movie but
it's so much more than that it's a
violent very
it's good as you make your violence I'm
like I want to watch it fits good really
yeah one of those and not unnecessary
you know how there's movie that's like
unnecessarily gory this the violence and
the blood it all has a purpose and it
has a point so it's not overly done but
it goes to school here makes a point
that's really cool to hear love it I
really I feel like I don't hear that
enough about actual violence and
meetings my number one choice is our
number three choice captain america
civil war in terms of summer movies this
movie was the ultimate summer movie I
mean there was a lot of height build
around it like who they do of course
they could do it but I thought it did
more than like I than what the Avengers
did the Avengers like delivered on the
humanity and humor and you know everyone
knows why the marriage is great but
captain america civil war managed to
bring in like interesting drama inside
of this movie with a nice touch of humor
throughout it's not like a comedy but
there is humor throughout the way they
rebooted Spiderman was brilliantly done
does their most personal film yeah
usually especially when you get like the
vengers 2.5 together you're expecting
just like chaos throughout but even
though there's like chaotic moments it's
still a very personal film even though
you could argue some fight scenes or may
not be the most senescent like
technically the airport fight scene
mm-hmm I've seen it twice it's not
really a necessary fight in the movie
but it doesn't matter at that point
that's what need it looks [ __ ]
amazing and it made enough sense at the
moment foot to occur you know and he's
gonna have a throwdown yeah exactly i
mean the apparent SAT giant man was
awesome it was the best use of cameos
and i really love what they did with
Tony Stark it was is the most emotional
performance we got of him despite what
you might say about iron man 2 I prefer
to his emotional tony start and this one
much more they still match making a
captain america film while still
providing this huge cast of characters
so captain america's never fully
outshine in any capacity even though
there's some scene stealers he's not
outshine if you get any black panther
like they matched introduced characters
or bring characters together they made
that this was their best full-blown MCU
film i think they've done i think it's
better than a vendor
and age of Ultron as well definitely
better than a jeho jump yeah for sure I
was worried about Black Panther because
he's never even had to see in a little
movie like some characters half so I was
like how are they going to even
introduce his background who he is and
have it all fit and not make it sound
like they're just shoving everything
into the movie but they did it no I like
it hate to say this DC fans but
everything bvs that a lot of people
didn't like Captain America got right
then that just the way it works yeah
when I complaint without we're not
comparing we're just explaining it's
just a way to you know use another movie
as an example yes for my number one I
have kubel and the two strings did you
get to see it I'm the biggest kubo
that's used rings fan yeah that's why I
made my list you hated it is it watch it
XO they got jobs again I love the
stop-motion animation I think that's
kind of a dying art and prompts the like
a studio because I know it takes them I
think like four years five years to put
the whole film together and this movie
when you're watching you forget that
you're watching stop-motion it looks
real life and just how real from a piece
of hair moving in the wind to a leaf
blowing to mixing the art of origami
into this film I meeting with seamless
along with the music and the voice
talents I mean one-half percent love
this movie you like maybe you want to
watch it accurate go see it haven't seen
a good stop motion film since chicken
run because you ever seen chicken right
L Gibson voice is one of the chickens
it's awesome oh I gotta watch it I gotta
check it out but know that because I was
seeing like what was the last one I
watching I did feel that way like yeah
but I saw the trailer for chicken run I
remember thinking i don't think i could
sit through a stop motion right then you
get pulled into it you forget you're
watching stop motion oh yeah i just
gotta give stop motion to change yeah
bring stop motion back and silent films
we all want silent films that's what all
the kids on YouTube want so we can all
read better read so open and subtitles
oh that sounds horrible I'm totally
joking I though just sign not gonna be
fun you want a dialogue would be very
necessary but you just can't hear all
right guys well that is our top 10
favorite movies at the summer of 2016
there's got to be a shorter way of
saying that I'm Greg subscribe to the
real rejects become a rejected a wendy
is part of collider videos and has her
own channel the movie couple where she
has a lot of movie talk on there as well
so go check her out on both of those
channels as she is a celebrity in my
eyes you make me feel good about myself
and John his best friend they're best
friends I went to visit in my hair out
Helen Hornets John scary aha way
mornings scary he's that guy who does
illegal things to you scary